this morning the supreme court hears
arguments in one of the most important
school prayer cases in more than a
decade that's why you saw a picture of
the supreme court involves a football
coach at a small town public high school
in washington state and whether he can
say a prayer at midfield after the game
now the school district told him he
cannot do that because it looks like
he's endorsing religion but the coach
says that violates his constitutional
rights to express his religious beliefs
jane crawford is outside the supreme
court with more on this story jan good
morning good to see you thanks gail good
morning you know this case really is
about where to draw that line on public
school teachers and coaches expressing
their religion as you said coach kennedy
said all he wants to do is say a prayer
on the field after a game and it's up to
the students whether or not they want to
join them but the school district says
he took it too far and it cost him his
job
it started just by myself just saying a
silent prayer by myself out on the
50-yard line
for years assistant football coach joe
kennedy said a short prayer on the field
after every game i would just take a
knee and thank god but soon his players
noticed after months a couple of players
asked me
what are you doing out there coach and i
said i was just thanking god for what
you guys did out there and well they
said can we join i said it's a free
country you didn't ask them oh god you
didn't say we're going to pray after the
game no the school is very they have one
rule in in their policy that says you
cannot encourage nor discourage kids in
prayer the solitary prayer grew to a
large huddle was it in jesus name or was
it more of a general prayer i would say
in your name because we have kids of all
different faiths a retired marine
kennedy says the on-field prayer is part
of what he says is a covenant he made
with god to give thanks but some parents
complained he is pressuring them to pray
students parents came forward and said
so much the school district in this
small town west of seattle told him in a
2015 letter to stop rachel lazar is head
of americans united for separation of
church and state which is supporting the
school district the coaches are
authority figures kids
admire them they want to please them and
that's why the courts have been so
careful to protect the religious freedom
of students this is about the game
kennedy temporarily stopped praying on
the field but then had a change of heart
prompting the district to later suspend
him he sued and the case now sets the
stage for a key supreme court ruling
testing the bounds of the constitutional
right to religious freedom kennedy says
the school district is discriminating
against him by prohibiting prayer the
school says it cannot allow the prayer
because it would look like it endorsed
it a california-based federal appeals
court sided with the district saying
kennedy was not engaging in private
prayer but instead was engaging in
public speech of an overtly religious
nature in the center of the field with
students who felt pressured to join him
students can huddle all they want and
that's fine and there's nothing coercive
about it it's when a teacher or a coach
gets involved and pressures them then it
becomes coercive how should the court
draw that line the line is prayer if he
wants to go pray on his own
that's fine even when he's on duty
that's where the big rub was they're
telling me where i can actually practice
my faith and everybody should be able to
practice their faith
now whatever the court decides obviously
could go well beyond the football field
and set new rules for prayer and public
schools and in recent years some
conservative justices have signaled that
they think the pendulum has gone too far
against prayer and almost amounts to
hostility toward religion and public
schools jamie
we'll be watching this one very closely
jan thank you